okay breaking news on capitol hill texas
congressman louis gomer we are just
getting word that he has tested positive
for covid19 the republican lawmaker was
scheduled to travel with the president
to texas this morning
and in the routine screening to board
air force one
he received the diagnosis after he was
tested
as you can see in that video there he's
taking off a mask he is however known to
not wear a mask around the capitol
and important to note he was at the
hearing yesterday
where attorney general bill barr
appeared as the key witness
so we are just getting this word now our
own john roberts bringing that reporting
to us and trace
we await more information as we have
calls and emails out to gomer's office
yeah a couple things we should note is
louie gomer is 66 years old he'll be 67
sometime in august in fact he'll be 67
on august 18th and you talked about the
fact that he
is against sometimes wearing a mask
around capitol hill he's done interviews
in recent days where
they have asked him about his reluctance
to wear masks around capitol hill
and he says the reason that he does not
wear a mask is because
he's been tested on a regular basis and
that
if he ever does test positive he said
quoting
you will not see me without a mask again
you mentioned yesterday's hearing with
attorney general bill barr
before the house judiciary committee the
chairman there gerald nadler
did chastise he criticized a number of
members for not wearing their mask louie
gohmert
was not among them in fact he was
wearing a mask you see the video right
there
but he has been prone not to wear the
mask in in
recent days and weeks and months around
capitol hill let's bring in our chief
white house correspondent john roberts
who actually confirmed this news he's
live for us
on the north lawn john what do we know
well you know it just goes to show
trace and sandra that you can test
negative for coronavirus one day
and then the next day you can test
positive for it that's happened with uh
at least one person here at the white
house it was negative one day
and then the next day tested positive
and had to take 14 days
off anybody who comes in proximity
to the president and this is
particularly true for people who fly
aboard
air force one or if we're in what's
called you know the press pool
uh that day we all get tested for
coronavirus uh louis gomer would have
gone through a
a a typical screening this morning it
probably would have been about seven
o'clock
since air force one was leaving in the
nine o'clock hour
and it happened that uh he came back
positive uh
what the white house medical office uses
is the abbott rapid test you get results
anywhere between
5 and 15 minutes so because he tested
positive
for that source is familiar with the
situation tell fox news that
gomer was removed from that trip to
odessa and midland where the president
is doing some fundraising this afternoon
as well as
offering some more help for the battered
oil and gas
sector testing positive for coronavirus
usually brings with it a convalescent
period uh that's anywhere from
10 days to sometimes depending on how
ill you get it could be a number of
weeks
texas congressman louis gomer from the
time that i have spent with him
in various situations is uh pretty
robust in terms of his health
uh i wouldn't expect at least on the
surface uh that his coronavirus
illness could bring with it uh
particularly deleterious effects
though he is in that age group that
sometimes can have severe bouts of
coronavirus disease
we should point out that he is the
second member of the freedom caucus by
the way
to test positive for coronavirus morgan
griffith republican of virginia
also tested positive and there was a
moment during yesterday's hearing
where the chairman jerry nadler
admonished a couple of
the republican members andy biggs as
well as
jim jordan to please wear masks in the
hearing
but what's ironic is that when nadler
issued his very strident
admonition he pulled down his mask in
order to do it
which is like not wearing a mask at all
if you've got a mask around your chin
it's the same thing as not wearing a
mask so
you know the whole idea of mask wearing
uh it it strikes a lot of debate
and sometimes a lot of tensions among
people i mean there was a man who was
shot and killed by police in detroit not
long ago
after he was ejected from a convenience
store for wearing a mask and stabbed a
person on the way out and later tried to
stab a police officer
said these confrontations about masks
can often escalate
into situations that people wouldn't
normally expect them to do of course
not seeing anything like that happen in
detroit uh they're in congress but uh
still tensions sometimes run high but
uh gomer not on on the trip today we
have uh
uh you know yet to hear anything
official from him
about what he's going to do but as you
pointed out that he said
if he came down with coronavirus disease
you would not see him
without a mask which is also kind of
ironic because once you go through a
convalescent period
you then have antibodies and you likely
wouldn't be positive for coronavirus the
time to wear a mask is
before you get it not after